comme pour le sang contaminé y aura-t-il
un grand procès pour défendre les
victimes de l'amiante montré les
défaillances et les responsables c'est
en tout cas ce que réclament ces
milliers de manifestants qui se sont
retrouvés à paris cet après midi en tête
de cortège des familles en deuil
florence magic and i tree boire un mari
un frère un cousin un grand père dont la
vie s'est arrêtée aux portes d'une usine
d'un atelier à bout de souffle
une mort inacceptable pour leurs proches
montfrin et 3 hier roissy
chez la france lele mora 55 ans en
grande souffrance ils étouffaient par
milliers des familles venues de toute la
france réclame une nouvelle fois justice
exaspéré par dix ans de lenteurs
judiciaires
nolaris on ne va pas demander d'aller
sur terre longueur de temps votre à dire
tranquille ont marqué notre vie on l'a
on a fait ce qu'on avait à faire mais
épuisé on veut qu'ils sont copains mais
j'ai quand même pas durer pour but
d'ouvrir un procès bon sens y aurait-il
ml l'enchevêtrement des foudres des
manquements des lâchetés mettre un
visage sur les responsables de ce drame
les voir à la barre d'un tribunal voilà
ce que veulent les proches des victimes
et les industriels de l'amiante
parce que eux savaient les dangers c'est
les employeurs qui n'ont pas respecté la
réglementation qui était censée protéger
les travailleurs c'est les pouvoirs
publics qui on le sait faire mais les
affaires sont souvent anciennes
les responsables du sinn parfois décédé
et il est impossible de prouver à quel
moment l'amiante a contaminé une
personne la maladie se déclenche
vingt ans après ne faut-il pas dans ces
conditions
modifier le code pénal nous escomptons
bien dans les années qui viennent que la
jurisprudence notamment de la cour de
cassation évolué pour qu'on se contente
d'un faisceau de présomptions et non pas
d'une certitude scientifique absolue
qu'on arrivera quand on n'arrivera
jamais à démontrer et n'allez pas croire
que recevoir des indemnisations
réconforte c'est vers ça nous donne rien
ça nous rend pas nommé bien au pas
croire
chaque année 3000 décès sont dus à
l'amiante en france certains
spécialistes estiment que cette bombe à
retardement pourrait tuer cent mille
personnes dans un futur proche